so it's my pleasure to introduce may
reach those people the monoplane is a
dozen Institute as previously it
Harville talked about computational
geometry of networks in various analysis
of mighty decided recordings photographs
indeed does anyone have any questions
this is this was you know you always get
badgered for titles and sometimes
sometimes you say enough okay here how's
that so these are ideas I've been
messing around with for well over a
decade and there were kind of mature and
extraordinarily difficult for me at the
time to explain but they're ideas that
require a very nice connectome to put
into practice so around 2005 we started
doing an e/m connectomics
I started playing around with these
ideas and maybe it's finally time to
finish these ideas because we're really
getting to the point where we might have
big enough graphs to test them out after
more than a decade so these are three
things that two things that one has when
you study the brain one thing you might
want to get when studying the brain
what are representations in the brain
and you know very obviously connectivity
with help for biophysics and
dynamics gives you physiology and also
just is obviously physiology over
development and even in true brains
through plasticity gives you
connectivity but what about
representations what about things we
might want to understand in finding out
the purpose of network and of individual
cells
classically one looks at inputs and
sensory systems behaviors and motor
systems or combinations of the two
and through physiology by looking at
input output relations you get things
that you might want to call
representations or vision it can be X
and y or theta and really not just those
that are the parameters but these are
but receptive field typically are our
functions of X Y theta velocity as you
percolate through the visual system the
parameterization might be gay angle for
face areas or face identity are the
other ways of getting at representations
and it's satisfying to me that that so
much of this workshop is about how one
can go from physiology to
representations through dimensionality
reduction manifold embedding etc through
various forms via various forms of
correlated activity
how can one go from connectivity to
representation and maybe this is
something that is obvious maybe maybe it
isn't but I haven't seen so much in the
literature about
and it's something I'd like to explore
in the next hour what we learn about a
representation in the absence of input
up if the geology again from physiology
we correlated activity I'm not going to
talk about dynamics and trajectories of
the way so much you know eel is talk and
other talks you'll hear just generalized
correlated activity what can one do with
connectivity can dimensionality
reduction use to understand connect
homes as well as multi neuron physiology
can the matrix connectivity matrix W IJ
be used to infer the geometry of a
representation and not just the geometry
transformations on representations and
but identically pretty much that the way
one can look at correlated activity to
get a representation one can look at
correlated connectivity so and this is
pretty much a story of my life back more
than twenty years ago the question I was
consumed with is how does virtual
physiology relate to single
thalamocortical connections and based on
the Hubel and Wiesel model of
connections from visual thalamus to
visual cortex there was a very simple
way that the labeled lines and the
thalamus might connect to labelled lines
that the neurons and visual cortex with
a certain physiology and in those days
we studied connectivity with temporal
analysis of two spike trains doing cross
correlations and looking for a delayed
peak and firing after the in the
putative or potential input cell fired
if there is a delayed peak and firing
like that that is very strong evidence
of connections let me introduce some
variables because they'll be throughout
the talk
the hubell and diesel model is about
connectivity on the one hand and very
very separately representations and
let's label the units this is a simple
cell which a simple cell is a bar
detector that for instance will see a
bright bar on a dark background in this
case so that's simple cell one that that
encodes of representation and that
representation is it responds to light
bars and a black background with this
certain oblique orientation it gets
inputs from LGN cells so for non-visual
physiologists L see it as an eye on the
input layer s is is the oriented filter
very much like a wavelet or Gabor
function or the first layer of a
convolutional network so these four
inputs l1 through l5 this four
representations they see points of light
on a dark background and those points of
light line up along where the
representation of the target is and
that's that's the model couldn't be
simpler over the ensuing twenty years we
essentially there are 15 years I guess
starting 15 years ago my group just
geared up techniques to get at the
generalized question how can you study
the function of cortical networks which
are massively interconnected and these
correlation techniques do not work how
can you study the function of a network
and the connectivity of the network and
first we applied the fairly new tool
then of calcium imaging in the cortex to
watch rather than listening to neurons
fire away watching them fire away I
won't show it but you can watch a
hundred now a thousand neurons at a time
responding to stimuli and you can map
what they do five years after that we
started to work on conic
comics on large-scale electron
microscopic eeehm reconstruction of
circuits and this is the second of two
papers that we did kind of hard to see
even maybe that's the point that here's
a huge network of cells this is a
hundred neurons that we reconstructed
the axons of about 30 neurons the
dendrites of about a hundred neurons and
map the connections between them but we
label those neurons according to what
they responded to the orientation that
they best responded to and did a bunch
of a ton of work and found the general
simple idea that a priori one would say
if that has to be true but you 10 15
years ago Dogma was that the cortical
circuit was random with respect to
function it was some magical pruning of
weights for just dynamics they gave you
it silly but that it was nice to have a
strong hand for all those years but
really it's proving to be true that the
cortical network is similar to the
thalamocortical network like - like
connectivity of coracle neurons neurons
red neurons respond to horizontal Green
to vertical stimuli and those form these
privileged networks sub networks of like
- like connectivity so
cortical functional conic comics we call
it we've been doing for about a decade
now and they're really only two papers
in this field one we didn't in 2012 and
one in 2016 they know that this is not a
fast quickly moving field the first
study had 200 connections a roughly a
thousand in less than 100 neurons the
second study which really gave the liked
to like was a thousand connections
amongst 100 neurons what are we doing
now we have this huge grant from a ARPA
who Collette who so our group myself a
new note DeCosta
doing the electron microscopy Sebastian
Seung doing the segmentation and you'll
hear a lot about segmentation from
Varenne later on andreas Tullius doing
the physiology what are we doing we're
reconstructing a cubic millimeter about
50 times larger than what we had done
before and with the magic of postmodern
segmentation of these data we expect we
will study 10 to the 5 neurons in this
cubic millimeter and we expect somewhere
between 10 million and hundreds of
millions of connections in this
connection matrix so what can we do it
with this huge object just just two
minutes here nolo myself two minutes on
experiments I was gonna show nothing but
someone said you've got to show
something so how are we going to study
10 to the 5 neurons a billion synapses
in a volume 25,000 40 nanometers
sections in order to make a 3d volume we
need to take a quarter billion images hi
you know 20 megapixel images put
together into a 3 or 4 peda box'll data
set and we're doing that with a bunch of
early 3e but now 6 electron microscopes
that are sort of tricked out in the way
that we started first at Harvard more
than a decade ago to make this
infinitely big data set let me very
quickly
Varenne will Oh golly I'm gonna have to
go through my browser ignore everything
good
what does the neuro pill look like that
this is one electron microscopic figure
and I can zoom in on the left and this
is what electron microscopy doesn't look
like all the grayscale stuff is what
electron microscopy looks like and you
can see these long things that are
dendrites and other gundarr yet another
dendrite you zoom in some more you see a
bunch of circles there those are
vesicles there's a synapse near there
I'm not going to find it but this is
colorized by these convolutional
networks that Sebastian Seung and his
colleagues Varenne Jane who's now at
Google and you'll hear from him have
used to trace these neurons by machine
and it's nice to be able to colorize one
section but it's extraordinary to be
able to these are serial sections it's
kind of fun this is what it the fun of
serial section am you can zoom through
in 3d following these things and the
convolutional networks follow in 3d
these shapes and one nice feature that I
was thinking about a lot yesterday in
Terry's talk are apical dendrites of of
neurons and another feature of apical
dendrites these sort of antennas that
that come out of neurons is that they go
in bundles that some people didn't
believe in but you hear I will prove to
you that apical dendrites go in bundles
just by clicking one let's click another
which click another let's click another
another another that was about six
months of a postdocs life previously in
doing and terry knows this you know yeah
he's done I was just talking to Tom Bart
all who wants this
tracing these things in three dimensions
there's one that has a cell body here's
another one
maybe here what's that's a hundred and
forty microns but imagine this embedded
in a cubic millimeter it's just it's
infinite so you can so this is a fun
tool that was built by Varennes team at
Google
and but the star of this show here is
the segmentation that Sebastian Seung's
team has done and that Brent is doing it
very similar at Google all these really
colossal bundles or is it's clusters
class yeah yeah I mean they're there
they're everywhere but they are they're
especially dense in these clusters so
let me talk go back to the real talk
what might we learn from a cubic
millimeter it's it's it's a really
obviously dense network but it's also a
hierarchical Network I won't
don't ask me then we can talk later how
you can get all the thalamic inputs but
you essentially trace them from there
where they enter the cortex and then you
have a label on it till they are four of
the cortex for current connections in
layer four to layer to three of the
network with the current connections
then on down to five and six and there's
a feedback this way it's a huge
hierarchical network with lots of
recurrent connections
let me just concentrate today from
thalamus to layer four to layer two
three and for the sake of argument this
this is all physiology and anatomy or
physiology from the cat but not the
month the mouse which we're doing now
but let's leave that alone
so this is equivalent to understanding
the transformation from point detectors
center-surround detectors to these
localized oriented filters these
wavelets called simple cells through the
next layer which is complex cells which
I'll talk about essentially but bunching
together
neurons grouping together neurons of the
same orientation but it's also extremely
similar to any hierarchical or any
convolutional network for vision
there's the input layer with the images
there's the first convolutional layer
which is always these wavelet like
things like simple cells and then the
second layer which people really they
throw up their hands and do all sorts of
visualizations for but to me and and
actually looking at it in detail it has
a lot of the flavor of a complex cell
layer and then all the way through so
actually the there is a between yeah the
left's lab labeled s and C there's
actually another set of cells called
yeah there's max going and those really
I mean that's equivalent I think to
accomplish so the max fully
yeah but actually so yeah but that's so
trivial I haven't analyzed it you know
it's part of the model and part of so
yeah maybe it's a complex so no it isn't
we'll talk about uno it is and it's so
simple it because it's just it's it's
taking one of the 96 kernels here and
doing it three by three max pooling and
that's not one complex those are complex
cells we'll take all comers different
simple cells of different so and that
that's this layer so there's sort of a
there's an output non-linearity and
translation you know but so now he
breaks down but I do think constitu is
closer so can we do this yes probably in
you know Davi Bach and I who started at
doing the con economics in 20 2006 his
first thesis project was doing exactly
this in the pathway from retina to
thalamus but these ideas given dense
enough reconstructions this should be
possible for a visual connect home and
the thalamic input could allow of
to interpret cortical networks so let's
do a computational experiment and
despite the title I'm going to spend
most the time on a hand-built cortical
network spend the last 15 minutes 10
minutes on Alex net at convolutional
Network and then just the last slide
which is sort of well the last slide is
is doing the physiology experiment to
match the anatomy experiment and I was
going to skip this slide but let me do
it very quickly
a local patchy visual cortex it's really
important to I I know you have issues
with this we head to the next slide it's
very important to be careful to not mix
a brain space where things live in the
brain with connection space you know
connect home you know a graph that can
have a layout or not and function and
representation in this case this picture
is actually a functional picture the
different colors express the function so
and this is really the theme of the talk
physiology will help us understand
wiring diagrams and wiring diagrams will
help us understand the physiology here
fatica lee I'm talking about local
networks and there's obviously a
continuum between local connections and
maps and and something called functional
architecture which is sort of a micro
map what I'm talking about it it is sort
of like in the continent the all of the
the weights that are trained but not the
weight sharing that happens all over the
network and in cortex there are maps of
functional architecture and that that
take on several dimensions they take on
X Y theta may be stereo but local
networks have hidden dimensions and
those hidden dimensions are the
receptive field attributes you know
phase and all sorts of things that that
have to
with different receptive fields
different function all mixed together in
a salt and pepper manner orientation is
mixed together in the mouse visual
cortex you know in a random fashion
that's kind of a dumb analogy but I
still like using it it's very similar to
the physical world where we live in the
easy to understand macroscopic 4
dimensional manifold but go down really
small and they're a bunch of hidden
dimensions seven six or seven hidden
dimensions that in in a local cortical
network there is space and in fact it
happens that there are hidden dimensions
of representation all the way down to
the single neurons that encode
dimensions that aren't visible
microscopically so here's the model
let's take an array of point detectors
these input or lgn and that are dis
Gaussian Xin space let's make 256
cortical cells which in the simplest
case are just elongated gaussians they
can have side lobes and stuff but it's
easier to discuss this case and easier
to compute but you can do both so you
have the representation which is a bunch
of points in space point detectors a
bunch of point and orientation detectors
256 of these orientation detectors at
different locations and different
orientations 14 by 14 grid of these
points the the size of these filters are
wrong you can see there this size so you
can see them all but the actual filters
are big on this grid and the rule is
very simple
the Hubel and Wiesel rule that you know
we worked on it's essentially the
strength of connection is proportional
to the overlap of the two receptive
fields the dot product so the weight
matrix W IJ is proportional to the
overlap of the two representation
the input receptive field the LGN
receptive field index by J and the
simple receptive field the oriented
wavelet receptive field but essentially
the weight matrix is equal to the dot
product of the representation of the two
representations of the two things that
may or may not be connected with a
certain weight so given this simple
linear relationship what determines the
connectivity that determines the
connectivity can we infer the
representation and this is either
trivially obvious or it takes a bit of
explaining which I'll do but essentially
the idea this is so over determined you
have a two dimensional manifold and you
have hundreds of functions on those two
dimensional manifolds that have very
simple rules of course you can
reconstruct that manifold so in the very
simple case where everything is on the
grid you get this weight matrix of the
input dimensions 144 by 256 and it it
has a diagonal structure it should be
that way but that's the way it plots are
shown anyway
step 1 find the latent variables that
are similar to the receptive fields
centers of the inputs so so we're trying
to get the the best parametrization of
the inputs and the inside is sort of
obvious if LG and receptive fields are
close together in space they connect to
the same targets so that will allow you
to make a pseudo distance between the
two LG n cells and you know just to
overdo it but I always whenever I give a
talk like this I under do it and people
don't get it but for this crowd this
might be a lot of overkill you just take
the covariance matrix of the LG endo
cortex connectivity essentially you do
wOHA transform x wi j and you're left
with a covariance matrix
is has the dimensionality of the inputs
one - that will give you something that
looks
one plus a [ __ ] that looks like a pseudo
distance no it goes to zero for far away
for for nearby sorry does that make
sense I I sort of muffed it in words but
it's very obviously good question uh I
felt proud that I figured this out
myself and I discover it oh my god
everyone knows this but hug that that's
what I'm doing right now here we have a
secret this is the actual distances and
those distances range up to a certain
amount
you know there's zero along the diagonal
I can get very far away for for in the
corners doesn't look anything like or it
looks a little bit like the correlation
one minus the correlation matrix but
yeah everything saturates great greater
than one so I scratch my head for a
couple of years in the time scale of
this long-term project and I read Oh
Dijkstra algorithm you know hit
Wikipedia or something so if you follow
that with a graph Dijkstra algorithm
sort of integrates out the local
distance and you get something that
looks identical to the actual distance
matrix Wow fantastic that's precisely
what I saw happen anyway so I did I so
math on this which is essentially take
the pseudo distance integrate out that
for things that have distance of one
service the asymptote and you get
something that's just like the actual
distance matrix and then you do multiple
scaling on it and you get exactly the
right answer this is what small this the
answer is this see start with the grid
that's secret but scramble everything up
and still you got you reconstruct the
grid just by doing this trick of
essentially find the correlation
coefficients of the weight matrix the
same way you'd find the correlation
coefficients of a physiology matrix you
know rather than
I mean over T in the correlation
coefficient of visi ology you sum over
the cortical targets and you get this
and it works beautifully here's the
that's slightly hard next part so we've
gotten the manifold of the input space
and that's that's kind of exciting and
then could potentially generalize you
know to the extent that the inputs to
any space any clerkly area look like a
manifold T's sort of non categorical
smooth parameterize able you might be
able to discover that in a word area
where you know we know from networks
that were you know semantics live in a
local vector space this might be kind of
general it might be a general cortical
feature so you can bootstrap your way
into the representation of the inputs
then take that bootstrapped
representation and just apply W the
weight matrix onto that representation
and you can get the representation of
the next level so essentially these are
the inputs but those are invisible
they're long gone or you have the
weights and applying the weight matrix
to the manifold embedding of the LD n
cells you get something that looks
almost well doesn't look almost
identical it looks highly similar you
know matching their edge effects here
but let's look in the middle that and
now like ELA I I did I allowed myself a
mirror reversal and a single rotation
and the the matching inferred
bootstrapped simple cell to that is that
that that so you really you can get into
the network and now I always in the past
lost people there so that this really
goes to again so we have an input space
V LG n cells l1 204 we have the output
space the s is
we have to connect home wi j what I've
done is bootstrapped into and got lrf of
or of x and y and apply W to get the sr
f of XY and it's sort of data and this
let's even keep going so that the
mapping from l2 s is w and these are
what the elements of L and s and here's
what it looks like
you know the again this is this tells
you what the players are and you have
this nice diagram that you see from your
youth in differential geometry or
something the connectome is this thing
it's just the mapping the linear mapping
this is the fun part doing ICM map or
MDS multidimensional scaling and get a
sort of pseudo projection it's not
exactly projection but of DL space to
the same units l but they're transformed
now to be functions of x and y you've
discovered the x and y parameterization
of these things induced by the wiring
diagram W and now it's sort of simple if
you have the same else just with an XY
label and you apply W to it you get the
esses and that's that's what what this
trick is you have the parameterization
of your space W selects the inputs and
gives outputs okay yeah so is that
correct
oh this is about the center
nicely yep so but that's the fun thing
so you you bootstrap your way into
exactly that I should have made it more
clear into inputs that are points
absolutely our points in a manifold and
and really what a receptive fields and
beings their functions on manifolds but
as long as the parameters well as long
as the inputs are simple enough and and
just the the location in parameter space
it could be ex-wife a tiff phase for
simple cells for instance that might be
good enough but it but once your boot
strapped in then you get functions on
the manifold the yes is a function on
the manifold but yep right so don't
trust me I wouldn't because I did
everything under grid look I'm gonna
rush through this you can randomize
everything and you have random locations
random orientations etc you get a
connection matrix that looks like
nothing but still you get the right
answer these are where the inputs live
and those little tiny tails are the
error the errors and you can do the same
trick so what about the second stage
what uh what about so what I did was the
thalamus at layer four what about layer
four to layer two three and again there
was this fifty year old model from
Huebel and diesel that there's things
call it's complex cells think of that is
conf two and the convolutional network
and this is essentially lumping together
a whole bunch of different the wavelets
all the same orientation yeah different
space different phases etc so we have s
is mapping onto C's and very quickly I'm
going to go through this model where you
can have the inputs that
our different positions different
orientations the outputs are now these
much larger spatial things but they have
different orientations and the rule is
grabbed from nearby orientations so this
is this building you know building out
the complex cell model and the color
code here is different orientations okay
build up that model and then do exactly
the same trick and in this case the
inputs are functions of X Y and theta
and we have it we have a different
diagram ask to see through this the mate
weight matrix project it that the same s
is on to parametrize set of that s is
and then you can get your complex cells
but the important thing is finding the
parameterization of the inputs and it
gets that the next slide little bit
complicated I use color here for the
orientation forget that in the next
slide the color code is x and y bright
nurse right brightness is the Y
dimension X is the color this is
feed-forward yeah you get all the same
principles hold and you you can't do the
trick you can't do this trick because
both both sides are the same units so
you can just get the parameterization
but it works pretty nicely and you can
go backwards and you get the
parameterization of the target space not
just the input space it generalizes
completely and you know essentially the
whole thing is not I bio
it's I layer one layer to the entire
matrix but it's it's sort of nice to do
the embedding cell type by cell type so
anyway you can embed this model into 4d
and you you it's it's it's you know it's
an built but it's just kind of fun to do
this and you really get our tube is one
you get a three dimensional manifold
that you have to do a forty
multi-dimensional scaling but as you
rotate this four dimensional point cloud
you can find the angles where you get
this the orientation direction and if
you get it just right along another
projection you get a retina Taavi
Y and X so it works for you know
recently complicated manifolds in a way
it's all a parlor trick that it's built
that way but it's fun to see that it
actually can work in the last some
number of minutes I'm going to apply the
same ideas to alex net which is you know
one of the very first highly successful
uses of a deep network it's specifically
to work on image net this huge image
data set for classification but it's an
N you know five or six layer
convolutional network their color images
and you get color first layer
convolutions what I had a friend
Gayathri Maha Lingam do a monochromatic
Alex net she just did everything in
black and white one channel rather than
three channels and so we have a bunch of
these wavelet like things in the first
layer and let's do exactly the same
thing I'm not going to show you that
it's you know it's really kind of
trivial going from int
space essentially pixels which you can
scramble and you unscramble the pixels
when you go through this month this
manifold embedding stage but let's look
at the interesting stage you know what
is conf - what does it look like and
most importantly what's the what's the
scene from con - what is the important
manifold that cond one lives on with
respect to grabbing things that are
similar you know that's what what you
know it's a function of a manifold and
continuity or something will give you
that things that are similar need to map
to the same place so again the input is
like the LGA and the cond one wavelet is
like simple cells con
two people really don't haven't said
much about it but what does it look like
so I've said this a hundred times so
cond one con Wanda con - what is that
mapping and here we go that there are
there's so many weights and so many so
conf - is quite large
it's the spatial kernel the spatial
support of these filters is five by five
by 96 it's not there - of these bags so
96 deep so it's 96 times 25 whatever
that is 24 100,000
elements that go into each one of these
and looking at all the potential inputs
you get something that looks very much
like a ring it's very small but can
people see I'm gonna go to the next
slide there are many versions with
different parameters you can take you
can take the inputs that map onto a
manifold with the least stress so but
there are all sorts of selections that
you can take to try to uncover the shape
of the manifold and here's a nice one
which is just abundantly clear that the
inputs cluster into something that looks
like a ring which alone you'd say yeah
maybe but here are the actual kernels
the the the wavelets that are at
different positions in this
one-dimensional manifold showed in
Joanie 2d or all the verticals hear all
those obliques they're horizontal the
other oblique so clearly come to layer
here's most in some sense the rules of
connectivity respect the proximity rule
as you would get with the s-1 just a
circle to do next and I've been playing
with this for a while you see if it
looks like r2 by s1 and and it actually
it does but one has to sort of unpack
the weight sharing of and let's ignore
that almost done
this is my one slide and there's not
much I'll walk through it this is
exactly the same thing so we have a plot
of a bunch of the input filters plotted
in 2d and the 2d
position of these filters is determined
by manifold embedding in this case
however the manifold embedding is not
acting on the graph it's acting on the
physiology so again Gayathri gave me the
activations of first convolutional the
output of the first convolutional
Network the activations of the second
convolutional networks to 300 different
images in image net and there are a lot
of numbers in that it's it's it it's a
27 by 27 grid of points and in the in
that convolution and I'm treating those
as independent it's your either
different neurons or you can better for
this thought experiment consider them
the same neurons seeing an image at
where you move the image around so you
have 27 squared positions times 300
images it's a lot of it's a very long
temporal vector or activation vector and
you do the dot product of those
activation vectors and you make a
correlation coefficient matrix again 96
by 96 of the inputs so it's a lot easier
than having to report that much it's a
lot easier I mean that's the beauty of
this you know you know and anyway so the
answer looks the same and the
tendentious point i want to make is that
particularly because of the sparsity
I think of the code they're very high
biases or low biases how you say these
neurons don't fire very much and some of
them fire almost not at all these units
it's a it's a noisier convolution I
think we're precise if you have more
examples boria books probably and that's
it's an easy thing to do I just have to
ask Gayathri to do it and she's busy
it would certainly I I made
I've got to set it up myself I if I put
all of the biases to zero then it would
be a very dense signal and it would be
probably much better so I'm essentially
done so
given like to like connectivity given
this the simple postulate of a heavy and
learning rule if a representation lives
on a manifold we can infer that
representation from the connectome so
that's the take-home point and you know
putting that into convolutional networks
I think it's an interesting I don't
really know but it seems like to me to
be an interesting research question
we're in a manifold we're in a
convolutional Network do things appear
not categorical or chaotic fractal or
whatever when do they appear a
continuous manifold like and when do
they not and my guess for cortical
networks is we already have maps we
already know the cortex likes continuous
representations my guess is that the
super guess is that a cortical column is
a principal component finder and it
picks out things that look like
directions
you know points in a manifold and
operates on them so it this might be
very general not just in early sensory
systems potentially we can take a
connecthome in bootstrap our way into
understanding the underlying
representation so it's not just
embedding the inputs into a manifold or
embedding anything into a manifold which
by definition gives you points in the
manifold not functions in a manifold you
have the transformations in the
connecthome as well so that's why it's
you know arguably richer but me Tia will
will disagree tomorrow I bet or today
arguably richer than doing it with
physiology because you have the
transformations built-in
yeah yeah absolutely I mean you know
this started from doing functional conic
Tomic sperm from doing physiology and
connectomics together but it is you know
I said let's let's be cute and let's try
it you know to imagine what you'd do if
you had a broker Wernicke connecthome
what would that look like and Alex that
we can go from con 1 and con from input
to convey 1 or con 1 to con 2 and show
this manifold embedding idea the ideas
work and essentially the idea is this
you know a connectome is a mapping and
it can be completely chaotic and you
know it doesn't doesn't need to be on
the manifold but in the cases I looked
at you can embed it in the manifold give
each unit of parameterization and then
operate on it by the connecthome itself
and you can even do this at multiple
stages so if you have all of this in one
piece yeah you you can go from L to SS
to see you can go from s XY to V yeah
you can add a projection from here there
are a lot of directions you can go in
this graph crawling through manifolds so
why stop there
go - come on 3i I haven't it's it's it's
a god-awful mess and I can't figure it
out and and this is a hobby I just like
it's sort of programming therapy in so
these are the questions in which cases
two representations live in a manifold
primary sensory motor certainly but what
about hidden units you know funky things
in the middle how often is that
representation derived from the
connectome so this is a question that
was something to yellow last night can
dynamics live on a load low D manifold
but not in the connectome you know I
think generally not I think the the
connectivity has to embody the manifold
but you know who
you know if you can modify weights
without modifying connectome proper who
knows and this is terras question you
know when it's physiology alone
sufficient best for honor for uncovering
the representation it's manifold and add
me alone or obviously both so these are
ideas those started doing with Davi Bach
experiments yes starting with postman
well Alonso and Mario sorry for the
human visa like experiments and then
Davi Bach way chun-li and now unit
Acosta on the conic comics and
discussions with these people
Thanks I want to come back to this
question if you have recurrent circuitry
and so the question is a little bit so
as long as your neurons live as points
on these pyramidal manifolds kind of
means that there is a feature of a
single neurons response so you can kind
of you know you can assign an
orientation to the activity of one
you're they're not looking at other
neurons but if this goes out of the
window so if you have extras you know
extra classical receptive field
properties of neurons so you know so my
question is if the neurons stop to live
as points of the manifold but there are
some manifolds maybe but they have to be
described by populations wrong by second
neurons how would this feel I have
similar answers to this question and
questions about the science that I like
to do feed-forward connections I believe
along with Murray Sherman and a lot of
people that cortical networks in
particular thymoma critical and critical
networks have a a feed-forward backbone
the the things that can make the neuron
fire everything else being
yeah the the data or whatever it being
in the right phase the right things
happening in this in the surround
etcetera etc etc I think all of these
manifold embedding things are finding
the backbone geometry and the all the
other stuff it I think it's extremely
complicated and arguably I think it's
stuff that you might be able to get with
connect home the you know but then so
that's my hand waving way of saying I'm
putting that off and I don't want to you
know understand how to answer that
question but I think the backbone is
important you know water is something
where the interactions pair with
molecules are gonna determine but then
it has all these states of matter right
you in this team there's ice there's
literally absolutely that emerge you
know that you know part of the stem
you've known circuits
indeed like in a sensory pathway there's
a lot of speed for word processing but
in our there you know cognitive circuits
we also know that can memory circuits a
lot of our models basically depend on
emergent you know stable states from
recurrent processing and that really is
the fundamental representation of this
inversion yep I'm with you completely
and and you know in my own brain and and
people who know me you and have a little
disclaimer up here play like speed
forward Network and the standard
question is Fritz's question but the
next question is your question dynamics
yeah yeah this is static this is static
and you know you might be able to get
dynamics from this
but I'm not counting on it tomorrow yes
I really bit it's a regularity but it's
necessary but not remotely sufficient
and sometimes it might not be necessary
sometimes there could be recurring
dynamics that come out of from my point
of view nowhere so absolutely so yeah
you can go from connections to dynamics
you know activity but it requires a
certain step where you have the plug the
connectivity into it and similarly you
know the other effort of course until
your beautiful work and others work for
Sebastian others to get connectomes
until then we were sort of stuck with
trying to and I guess each one has its
own absolutely and you know I think
different places different different
principles in places where inherent
dynamics find the attractors that our
memories sure again so
I think you have to distinguish between
the in terms of the the actual function
between patterns that are you're very
familiar with right that you're you see
faces all the time
for example and you recognize them
really quickly in fact who is that that
did this experiment where he showed that
done if you take things like you know
Eiffel Tower and so forth and look at
the responses of the you know the output
it's almost you know there's not enough
time to do any processing except the
feed forward pass and then you get the
output but as soon as you give someone a
more complex image to analyze then it
takes longer because it does have to
circulate a little bit longer for the
you know for the computation to settle
and by the way that this is Jim DeCarlo
has done a followed up on his original
work which we heard about on Monday
Monday morning the first time which has
to do with looking at comparing the time
it takes a monkey to get the right
answer and whether or not the confident
Alex DUP gets the right answer so it
turns out if you take the the images
that Alex that gets wrong it takes the
monkey 30 milliseconds longer to get the
right answer suggesting that that's
what's going on functionally in other
words the network has feedback it has
lateral interactions and and you need
really need to have to do their problems
so actually I have some question about
the foundation of this question about
connectomics the importance of
unemployment because for our
understanding of Education when that
liberal talk about it tomorrow
a little bit they're actually infinitely
many random configurations which are as
optimal as far as achieving the goal and
it's only a fallacy to talk about one
optimal brain and in terms of the
connections of the scientists you have
any any way of actually comparing two
different brains in the same tissue
let's say well there's a lot there so
let me let me know there's a lot there
clearly the individual things are gonna
be different I would wager in these that
the underlying manifold is gonna be the
same and maybe media will talk about
similar ideas yes baby
okay I'm sorry to keep putting words in
your mouth from our second conversation
um however I want to strongly object
disagree with the idea of optimality and
of criminally useful you know I I never
claimed this is optimal but I'm but I
might claim I might claim that evidence
is pointing towards this being true you
know so in in in the network so it won't
be true everywhere if you know empirical
results about the connectome empirical
results about physiology and
representations those are what they are
and you know nature could have solved it
a whole bunch of different ways but I
you know that my big belief is that the
cortex solves it in one way and
particularly these sort of overtrain
parts of cortex that have a lifetime to
develop I do think that they have
heaven rules ie like to like
conductivity and they seek out and
operate on low dimensional things that
can be transformed by finding these
correlations in the input so so but but
but you know can be very very different
of course you can be different but what
I'm saying is when you look at a
thousand cats or mice you find this and
and every cell is different you know
it's biology but the underlying rules ie
locality in in space tuning for
orientation those things those things
are remarkably constant I don't talk
about the rules I think the principles
are important and that another universal
but the details of the interconnection
is just like trying to find the detail
there this is this this I'm going to
keep arguing because for whatever reason
the the strongest complaint that people
have about connectomics is precisely
that word details the same thing could
be said about physiology of neurons the
details of spike timing it can't be
important because it's going to be
different from time to time from neuron
to neuron to yeah I don't care about the
details I do but I care about the
regularities and you know yeah that
that's that science you know you yeah
everything is different every every
ensemble of atoms in a gas is different
but thermodynamics works because it goes
to to a certain place so what anyway
we'll talk later and this is turning
into a
it's the economy beep forward to
feedback and so just look at the retina
one must seven feedback networks there
with the horizontal something that she
needs back to the percent and indeed let
you know that the backbone of the city
is this vertical pathway that goes from
four centers divided by the paper itself
but if you threw out doors all cells
that we probably forgot the baby with
the bathwater the resident right this is
so I think it's so so it's I think it
could be fundamentally important it's
fine I got one baby but it's not
throwing out another baby it's not
throwing out the spatial locality of
coding it's throwing out a you know a
gain control mechanism uh bells and
whistles yeah yeah I'm ignoring I'm
doing hen neglects to room helps you
picture so I guess I'm to suggestions
why is that if you use that Alex knife
is similar to our work that if you scuba
net and vgt would you have the same nice
random like 1095 I don't know I was just
talking to Michael bass about this and
using about very deep networks versus
shallow networks deep networks with
small support you know 3x3 and shallow
networks with larger support 11 by 11 5
by 5 and got feeling no proof is that
these 50 hundred deep networks with very
small support probably get a lot more
baroque in the inner and said that you
know they probably do each layer isn't
looking in the same way for the manifold
than the layer but beneath it that you
know the structures can be mixing layers
a lot more totally vague but I don't
think it'll work for a deep deep narrow
network
it might be interesting to try and yeah
this is a hobby really like narrative
and story but I'm also here to see can
you keep some quantitative metric on how
your theory fits the data yeah one one
metric I'm just beginning to play around
with is this stress or error signal how
far away the points are from the optimal
placement in the manifold and yeah you
could in a way yeah there are million
questions that one can do put is
searching for turning into something
that I can assign to north hola sofy is
why do I like the cortex the cortex is a
highly highly conserved
computer that is extraordinarily general
and I think it might the problem the
cortex might be a far simpler problem
you know these modules do something you
know that they don't know code this or
that or the other thing and they don't
have precisely these characteristics for
any given neuron but in this theory I
want to even call it that they're just a
an array of neurons that can find
manifolds or if you know find
correlations that's throw away that
weird manifold find correlations in the
inputs operate on them transform them a
little bit and send them on to the next
level that's a very simple thing that
you know the principles might be fairly
straightforward Drosophila is you know a
hundred million years of large menu of
evolution optimizing a small number of
neurons it's a it's probably but it's a
bag of tricks in much of it they're
they're parts of their Safa that
probably are simple in the way I'm
calling simple and might might be more
amenable to understanding you know the
structure of computation then the highly
evolved highly specialized parts very
vague answer but I do I do too deeply
believe that the cortex may be far
simpler in its generality and more
powerful that's that's why you know why
we're us - oh absolutely yeah and we're
presently doing the v1 v2 order but no
exactly the program is v1 v2 but
seriously you know Broca's area you know
wouldn't it be amazing to find you know
like I can I won't even say it out loud
but wouldn't it be amazing to find
similar principles
of finding directions that you can see
in the connectome that parameters that
encode something that get transformed so
it does not mall building questions I
beat Sevilla the discussion center
section I have a burning question this
is what the complex cells look like by
the way for anyone who wants to but no
Dana's been raising his hand for ever
just one point out there's a recent very
beautiful experiment with the rat
running on the treadmill where the
vision the visual input is in concert
with a running or discus parrots and
turns out that they're in the thalamus
their separate buses to take the signal
from the things you can predict and the
things you can't predict so I'm with it
this is very the concert the way I thing
but is that vision is really about
prediction and the only things the only
novel things you say see are the things
you didn't predict and so there and we
also know that the feedback connections
are ten times the feed-forward so it's
important it's really important to do
what you're doing to get it before
pathway sorted out that's great but if
you want to see how the thing being used
you have to look at the bigger picture
is gonna dominate but you know what one
thing about punitive lee powerful
techniques like conduct comics is you
get a class of questions of why not this
too and you know you make your choices
about what to look for and i would love
to do feedback i've tried to do feedback
it once or twice it's just hard and
people many people have wrecked their
ships of research programs on the shoals
of you know trying to find you know
robust phenomena of the neurophysiology
of feedback so
I'm conservative so we found this them
correctly you're able to go from
connectivity to representation crucially
because in in a visual system
there's light to light connectivity so
URLs that have similar presentation
similar receptive field they have
similar connectivity but I wonder or if
you use your approached to cases where
there is not like a like connectivity
well what were you inside would you be
able to again sir I can think of several
examples you know for example the fly or
factory Bob the mushroom connective
that's less random or if you you might
think about your lgn to be one model if
if there's actually not like - like
connectivity so if you know and your
else have the same connectivity you have
uncorrelated receptive fields what will
happen or if you have don't have a good
idea of what the representation is what
will haven't even used the first three
or four things yeah it won't work if the
rules are extremely complex if if there
is no reliable similarity metric or anti
similarity metric you're not these
tricks are not going to work but the
last thing you said you know in your
frontal cortex you don't know the rules
I guess I have a very strong prior about
cortical networks born out of you know
years of looking at these things that
the excitatory to excitatory connections
always the the feed-forward ish know
even the lateral so the I don't know
about feedback but the other two
feed-forward and lateral excitatory to
excitatory connections all so far appear
to be like to like yeah the whole that
the network my including inhibition and
different cell types and feedback and
all sorts of things might try to dampen
down that like to like in order to
create sparsity or
etc but I just everywhere I've looked
and an increasing number of people have
looked there seems to be like - like
connectivity and you know there is head
there's bien phu you know it's it's
that's yes if even your prefrontal
cortex you do have like - like
connectivity but we don't know the
receptive fields of those neurons what
do you give well that's sort of what I
wish I had said more clearly that that's
exactly what what you know vision I
understand
and these things are going to be true
wish they'll be truthy and early vision
would it be amazing and I don't know if
this is true wouldn't be amazing is as
we go to random cortical networks even
if we don't understand them we can say
ok let's play this game the inputs seem
to cluster but seem to look like our to
cross s1 you know I I can do clays sort
of look and see I can do nice term I
looked up on Wikipedia yesterday
persistent homology you can do things
like that and say wow there's a robust
thing telling me that the manifold
locally looks like this so I have no
idea what these dimensions are but let's
let's go in and see what the cortex does
with it so that that's sort of the
general idea which may or may not work
ok break
[Applause]